look I think the strategic issue we
faced was at the beginning of this year
right and that the question there was I
think when you looked at
january-february what do you do with
your business when everybody was worried
about the world and everybody was down
and you're starting to figure out well
hop you know how do you position
yourself I I think for us we ended up as
a firm having everybody focused on one
goal and that goal was we need to
absolutely differentiate ourselves this
year from everyone else because if we
don't differentiate ourselves the firm
is going to have a number of issues and
I think it was having everybody focused
as one on making sure that we could
produce I think very good returns for
people i think was it strategic i just
don't think we had a choice right so yes
it was strategic but ultimately what you
find with strategic issues is you've got
to figure out where you want your firm
to go and sort of the big changes that
you want to go I think the big one for
us if you don't count this year was
about sort of nine years ago we made a
strategic decision to go to Asia and
sort of for us we thought that Asia
would be where there was going to be a
lot of growth I think a lot of people
thought that you know how did we do it
we ended up opening offices throughout
Asia and you know there's a real cost to
doing that opening our office in New
Delhi in Bangkok in Jakarta in Beijing
and Shanghai Manila so when you sort of
look at that there's there was a cost
that it was going to cost us a lot of
money to do it but we thought over time
we would be correct so strategically at
the time I think people thought we were
too early and it turned out that we were
right but I still think we were too
early here when we started 1999 we did
it right after the asian crisis and I
think people would have said you needed
to wait
I I think a lot of sort of strategic
decisions do you want to just focus on
the stress I think for us we made a big
decision that we thought things we're
going to get worse I think as we talked
earlier in 06 you know we were
ultimately right but we were too early
right so I think there's a lot of
fundamental things that people do the
question really ends up being do you
have the luxury of time to be right